[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are going to be pulling back
another curtain
and behind that curtain is two men
who have been going to therapy for
certain lengths of time and we're just
going to do a little check-in i thought
you were going to say you're going to
put by the curtain and it's two minutes
our therapist uh they're not joining us
they're not joining us we can say
anything we want about our therapist um
but we won't well we will
we're gonna be talking about
our experience thus far
in therapy and how we're viewing that
what kind of stuff is happening
and let me just just in case you're
immediately like i don't care
i'm not from los angeles you guys
obviously are listen therapy is not just
for boys in los angeles therapy can be
for anybody um
we uh and it's been beneficial to us we
don't know if any
we don't know if you think that but
we used to think that yeah yeah we're
speaking to our former selves um and
we've therapy's come up
a lot in conversations because we're
talking about you know processing our
lives and therapy is an uh a big part of
that an important part of it
um but we have a hair
that oh i can see it there we go i know
you don't like one hair or in that place
or out of place and if people don't
point it out you get upset so i'm just
letting you know right now i don't want
you to be looking back at this and be
like why'd you let me do that the whole
time i'd hate for my therapist to be the
one to bring it up
but what we haven't done is devote an
extended conversation to the topic in
some time if ever so um now's that time
uh i will say i have a little uh update
recent travel excursion
um
too i mean thankfully you know
um
certain places in the country have kind
of you know we're not out of the
pandemic but certain there's certain
places and if you take certain
precautions you can feel somewhat uh
safe to travel
i've kind of taken advantage of that but
also this was a wedding of a friend that
took place in kansas city that i was
going to go to regardless
but thankfully i could sort of feel safe
in doing so uh but
the most notable thing besides a
beautiful wedding beautiful couple
getting married and beginning a
beautiful life together which is not
what i'm going to talk about
is the fact that we stayed at a haunted
hotel okay now you know me i you know
i'm into horror stuff i like the idea of
haunting
i'm pretty skeptical about
the paranormal
i can act like i'm really into it but
the the in my heart of hearts in my
heart of hearts i'm just
this is probably all made up right
but that did not stop me from being very
enthusiastic about the ghost tour and
this is coming from someone who's been
on a few ghost tours it's hard
to get enthusiastic the two that i went
on with you and one in new orleans and
what was the other one london jack was
the jack the ripper tour that's right um
oh boy i just i kind of needed to just
turn in for the night about halfway
through well let me tell you why i was
particularly excited about this one
both of those ghost tours were going
around the city and then like coming up
to a corner and looking at a building
and hearing somebody who had just been
told information
what to say about this thing are you
telling me you had an actual ghost give
the tour well it wasn't that good but
it's somewhere between
the original experience and that which
is a ghost tour of a hotel
where you are staying first of all okay
we're in a different category
and secondly uh well there's actually
three points to this the second point is
the points are expanding the guy doing
the tour and this isn't something i knew
ahead of time but the guy doing the tour
wasn't just talking about things that
other people had said he was telling his
own stories
and being an employee for 15 years at
the hotel so many of his stories were
like this happened to me
again never experienced that
and then the third thing
was um
the bride and groom hadn't had
experienced
some metaphysical unexplained phenomena
you might say okay what
the first night in the hotel well when
you're consummating a marriage the night
before well the night before the ghosts
would go really wild when the night
before the ghost tour so
oh and also locke told me that something
happened in his room i'll tell you about
that a second
apparently
they
they wake up and the bedside table
little
deal with a drawer it's a drawer what
would you call a bedside little thing
that's got a drawer
my bedside table's got two drawers man
my previous one had three i don't think
that's technically a table like if in
furniture speak i don't think it's a
table if it's got a drawer bedside chest
of drawers definitely not that there's
probably like a french word for it i'd
like to get to the haunted part uh the
drawer had opened
in the night okay
okay well that can happen they close the
drawer
and the drawer opens again before their
very eyes now this could be like the
gravity of the you know it could be like
the floor it's the old hotel like the
gravity can open with the drawers
yeah but then
the
a water bottle
like a whatever you know the one that
you have one everybody's got like a
nalgene no the like hydroflask
hydroflash so like like a metal water
bottle was on that same table
and
it at some point in this process began
to do that thing where you know like a
bottle isn't quite settling and it's
kind of like
kind of rotating a little bit like right
before like a coin settling and then
stopping okay yeah
that was happening but it was just
happening indefinitely
it was just like okay this bottle is
gonna do this they're just watching it
and they stopped it and put it back down
and it started doing it again
and then they were just like okay
you can you can have in you can have
your drawer open i don't know exactly
the sequence of events but because i
kind of heard it as they were telling a
group of people and i was it was enough
for me to be freaked out i have an
explanation for that there's vibration
in the hotel from like hey listen
laundry room there's always another
elevator shaft i told you i'm just gonna
vibration takes care of everything i've
heard so far but of course and every
single thing i'm gonna tell you i'm not
gonna tell you everything that happens
on the ghost story but everything every
single thing i was told because like
locke and shepard after the ghost story
because locke had heard somebody
whispering in the vent at like 3 a.m
uh in in loch and shepard's room and
then he actually told the guy on the
ghost tour that the guy giving the tour
and he was like that's just because all
our the whole system is connected so you
just heard somebody whispering in
another room he wasn't like feeding into
it that's maintaining credibility he's
kind of like the pope he's like i'm the
only one who can tell ghost stories well
no no because he was he had
many people on the tour were saying
things that had happened to them or
and he was validating some things but if
it was if he i actually thought it was
he's keeping it real but when loch and
shepard were after the tour they were
like dad what do you think about this i
was like well you wanna know what i
really think
uh i was scared at multiple points on
that ghost tour especially the moment
when we were standing at the stop top of
the stairs and some little girls who
apparently knew that the ghost tour
comes by their room and they could hear
uh
the guy talking
jay is his name talk he's he's actually
he's wearing one of those headset
microphones with a speaker that's around
his neck like a tour guide does you know
what i'm saying so that he can just
speak in a normal volume but everyone
can hear him so he's like coming by your
room you know oh jay's there he's doing
the tour
they waited until he had he was in the
middle of the story and they started
going and he had already just told us a
story about somebody being in a room and
seeing the handle move and so then he's
telling us a story and that's when these
little girls in the room start
like taking their door like shaking it
and me and lock and shepard were like
standing a little bit down the hall and
we immediately run up next to the tour
guide
you know before you have time to process
oh this is probably somebody just
playing a trick but i still was just
legitimately scared did the girls come
out and say gotcha they just laughed
with from him in the room which actually
was sort of creepy a little girl laughed
her through a door
but i said having said all that
i believe
that if you just if you put me you know
put my back against the wall and tell me
i've got to give you an honest answer i
think there's probably
a natural explanation for all this
there's a reason that it happens at
night there's a reason that it happens
during the so-called witching hour you
know after 3am that's because you're
usually you've been asleep and you're
waking up and you're not your senses
aren't complete you're just pouring
water on yourself now
are you okay it was haunted man
my tea was haunted so in other words
what i'm saying is that i think that
there's probably probably almost always
a natural
explanation but i'm not sure i'm open to
the fact that that's not fun places can
be haunted and it's more fun to believe
that the place is haunted
so
and this guy jay he's uh oh this is the
other thing that happened
uh
we're
a lot of famous people have been to this
hotel in fact the room that the bride
and groom were staying in is the room
that harry truman slept and the night
that he found out that he won the
presidency he went to sleep thinking
that he had lost and they woke him up at
like 2 a.m and said sir you won and then
there's another room that is a rumor
like al capone would come and play cards
and stuff and they're like he would sit
right here and he could see
this through this window and this window
he had both entrances covered in case
the feds came and he could go out this
way or whatever so it's been around you
know 100 years it's got a storied
history where is it it is outside of
kansas city missouri okay so he's
telling a story about some famous person
that was on the tour and then i can't
remember who it was so then we get to
the next spot and i kind of
me and locke and shepard were sort of
ahead of everybody we kind of walk up
and we're right next to him and kind of
waiting for the group to gather he said
and he was like
you look like a famous guy
um you famous
how may i include you in subsequent tour
mentions and i was like uh you know i
never know how to answer that question
so i was like
to some people yeah and he was like
naked and afraid
okay did he was he changing the subject
or was
he thinking you were on that show
he thought he was like i was a guy
because i was like no um i've been naked
and afraid on youtube
i haven't been on that show
but naked just because he said that no
he no he said oh there's a guy that
there's a guy on season so and so naked
afraid that
looked a lot like you
but then but then the next day
when i see jay and now of course we're
all masked as we're walking around this
thing so
and of course if you don't watch our
content regularly and you see me now you
may not immediately recognize me because
my hair is so different so the next day
he's like hey man
good mythical morning of course
i didn't put it together like my
daughter
watches a lot and i watch it with her
so love what you guys do
but
but still not negative
i thought you were from naked
you got demoted overnight man so shout
out to jay at the it's the elms hotel
historic hotel
they have a european lap pool
in the basement do you know what a
european it's like an indoor it's just
like a ditch that it's it's a track that
goes in a circle that you see oh a track
it's like it's it's a canal it's a ring
that's a wide note that's wide enough
for a person to swim in and it goes in a
circle it's it's it's kind of awesome
and when you get to the end of one side
there's a circle there's a little end
well it's an oval it's very long oval
like this
at one end of the oval
uh well it wanted an oval there's a
ghost
of course right uh but i'm afraid at the
other end there's a hot tub and a cold
plunge pool right next to each other so
we had fun kind of going back and forth
between those but i've never seen a
a race track
made of water there's a part of me that
was just like how necessary is this
because it couldn't just be oh i swam in
it's like oh yeah what was it like
turning bank in the corners nascar yeah
i mean i felt like i was about to come
right out of that thing well as long as
you are going around those corners there
was your like feet and hands hitting
it's big wow it's in the very
they probably just were going to make a
pool and then they were like you know
what
let's just fill in the middle except for
a little bit and let's call it a
european
swim track no one knows i think it's the
only european lap pool in america what
that's what they said i think okay yeah
i said in missouri hey listen once you
start
blurring the lines of truth with ghost
tours you can say anything you want you
can't believe these people they're not
credible anymore neither are you i'll
tell you right now if you have an
opportunity to go into a european lap
pool and if you're in america that may
only be available to you
in uh the elms hotel apparently in
missouri
excelsior springs i think is the name of
it okay you should go do it and swim
some laps
all right
let's dive into some therapy oh is this
gonna hurt but first
we're gonna we're in the midst of a huge
black friday sale
yep and it's and it's over the weekend
this comes out on sunday this video
version and so the the 40 that you can
get on sunday and you could have gotten
the last two days off of everything at
mythical.com
we're extending it through cyber monday
through tomorrow um
you can still get that forty percent off
through the end of the day okay you can
also have a good day tomorrow which is
monday you can also get 25 off mythical
society monthly memberships
uh mythicalsociety.com through the end
of tomorrow monday we're extending it
for you so take advantage take advantage
take advantage of this stuff guys
discounts are rolling in there's also
discontinued items that are returning
for one day only and that is tomorrow
cyber monday
uh coming out of the mythical vault
mythical.com
check those discontinued but recontinue
just for that day
tomorrow
get it mythical.com and
mythicalsociety.com
oh that felt good it feels so good feel
good to do that ad just like therapy
just like the
just knowing that people are getting
discounts
40 is deep
yeah should we even do that can we call
it can we can we can we decide something
different right now
where do we begin
um i think that's the name of esther
perel's podcast
or how was your day or how's work
there's two of them she's a therapist
she's great she's pretty great
she's not my therapist this will not be
as good as an episode of esther perel's
podcast no estere
well if you know her well it's esther no
no no no it's not quite the opposite
she's not quite the opposite she says
quit emphasizing the stare
emphasize the s you know you've crossed
over
but where where do we want to start with
it well let's just let's just let's give
some background about how long we've
been going to therapy maybe what maybe
what got us into it these are things
that have come up before but just for
the cohesiveness of this of where we're
headed
um and since you've been going to
therapy longer you go first
i think that it was 2017.
2017 was the end uh or the beginning of
didn't last long the longer version of
good mythical morning if you do recall
that where we did a bunch of videos
every single day
and my wife had been going to therapy
for a couple of years at that point and
had been asking me
or telling me
that i should be going
based on
things that she was learning about
herself that were then immediately sort
of transferring to me
because i think she like me thought that
i didn't need therapy do you know what i
mean
she knew she thought that okay i think
that she thought that the one with the
things that needed to be addressed from
a professional standpoint it was
probably her right because she struggled
with ocd since
since she was a young child so there was
like diagnosable things ocd and
depression that she
knew she had and had been professionally
diagnosed by like a psychiatrist years
and years ago
and i had never had that and i had
always sort of presented myself as well
you know i mean i'm super stable and
reliable and i'm not saying i'm perfect
but i don't think i need professional
help
when it comes to like my mental and
emotional health but as she began to
explore her own and realize that oh it's
not just about addressing this diagnosis
but there's a whole lot more to therapy
in the same way that you might have a
physical problem like oh i hurt my knee
in this very specific way i need to go
to the doctor well even if you haven't
hurt your knee you're a person with a
body and there are ongoing needs to
having a regular physical checkup you
see the analogy here so i do as she
started to talk to me she also started
to be able to see the way that i was
sort of dealing with the immense amount
of stress that had built up in my life
over the many many years of our
this mythical thing growing to where it
had and our schedule being crazy and the
amount of weight and pressure on us to
perform and to keep growing the business
and to be relevant and all the things
that come with being a public
personality
and she she started saying you really
should go to therapy and i think you
should just go to my guy because he's
great and he's open to doing open to
doing that you know having both of us so
anyway after and when at the end of 2017
in the midst of all that stress i had
some physical problems that developed
that did definitely seem to be stress
related i've talked about that before
that was when i started but just i mean
to give them the blurb though
well you went i had multiple
multiple
blindness you know i've had multiple
things that are known to be stress
induced like skin issues like psoriasis
and eczema back issues cannot often so
i'd always had those but the straw that
broke the camel's back
was when i developed central serous
retinopathy which is literally when
there's like a
fluid
sac
that gets behind your eye and creates a
blind spot
on your eye in your field of vision and
it was first observed or maybe not
observed but first sort of recognized
and labeled
uh when these world war
one or two pilots were coming back from
war and a bunch of them had this
condition because they had been under so
much stress
so there's reason to believe that it's
stress induced
and it is not permanent if it happens
once it's not unlikely to happen again
but anyway
i go to the doctor the eye doctor they
tell me that's what this is it's going
to take you know
months for this thing to resolve itself
which it did
for a while i think i can't remember
which eye it was but i basically
couldn't see in the middle of my field
of vision with one of my eyes you know
if it was like it was like black well it
was
blurry and wavy and made you feel like
you're having vertigo and he made a
connection to
stress or some inner inner mental work i
made the connection to stress when i
started reading about that condition
and i was like man okay i yeah i i guess
because i always would say i don't feel
stressed
because well i'll talk about what my
process is and what i've been working on
but it was because i wasn't dealing with
it in an emotional way i was dealing
with it in a physical way i do believe
and i don't understand and i don't have
the science to back it up but i do
believe that
there's a natural connection to when you
don't process things emotionally that it
kind of
it finds a way to get out of you and it
can rep it can manifest itself
physically so
that's what led to me having my first
appointment in sometime in like late
2017 so it's crazy to think that
coming up on
four years
of therapy i'm coming up on two years of
therapy in like the january february
time frame
so that means i started
like
just a couple of months had a couple of
in-person sessions before the pandemic
hit and we went to
zoom meetings
and um
for for me it's been
pretty much
every week except when like
scheduling challenges or
or trips or whatever but yeah the reason
why
i got into it
the best that i can remember is
yeah cr christy had
um had had a few therapists for many
years and had had been very open and
experienced the benefits
of that
of going to therapy back back home in
north carolina and
then out here when we moved out here and
like
uh all of the all the stresses and
everything associated with that
um
therapy re-entered her life and
you know we always had a really positive
view of it because she had
a very positive and helpful experience
with it and of course we're talking to
jesse she's having positive experiences
and then
you get on board
and you start having positive
experiences
and i was always very open to it
but i think in a similar way that you're
describing
it
was well i'll say that
i started going because
christy kept encouraging me and
i was benefiting from hearing uh from
how everybody else was benefiting from
therapy so i felt like i was getting
therapy by proxy and i was you know i've
made jokes about that
but
in a way to acknowledge that like
i'm i'm warming up to this i wasn't
opposed to it but i didn't feel like i
had an urgent need to to go to therapy
like to run there to fix a specific
problem i didn't think that i had
any problems that that needed therapy
meanwhile i was wrong meanwhile i mean
we never i don't know if we've ever
talked about this but meanwhile like me
and jesse and christy
would talk about
but when is link gonna go to therapy
yeah and and sometimes i would be there
but like it's like it wasn't weird it
wasn't like when do we intervene i can't
really talk to someone
you know you have to let somebody come
to that decision on their own i would
say that for anybody who like thinks
that somebody in your life needs to go
or you've you you've experienced
something you're like oh man i wish that
they could experience this right
you can't force them into it
and well your spouse can kind of do that
yeah uh depending on the nature of your
relationship it it became more of like
i'm going to do this i have plans to do
this
but they're not
it's not pressing and it's not imminent
so i'm going to just keep back burnering
it for probably a couple of years
in the meantime
i i would read books a lot of the books
that christy was reading of the like
introspective self-help self-discovery
variety like
stuff that she would be recommended by
her therapist or that she would take to
therapy so it was like an extension of
that i would read those books and i
would start to feel
the benefits of that
and so i think the thing that got me
over the hump was
i
as a result of my
spiritual deconstruction and my ongoing
spiritual journey
and really coming to grips with my
priority of in
doing the work as they say to like
really invest in myself and
understanding myself discovering more
and
just um i knew there were things in my
past
that affect me now and i was fascinated
by that and i knew i could benefit from
it
so when i started going it was like
i know i'm
i experienced a lot of anxiety
and i do want help with that
um you know there was like an opening
meeting the way that i found my
therapist was on uh like
psychology.com they have you can search
for somebody locally and you can read
reviews and
and there was an initial
interview process
which if you want to you can tell how
you met your therapist but with mine it
was like i i didn't have a personal
recommendation
i just had an interview meeting phone
call and i remember in that meeting i i
kind of just laid it all out i was like
you know i want to send the message that
like
i'm i'm an open book and i'm all in for
however i can benefit from this and i
know that i i deal with anxiety and i
know that i have things in my past
um when it came to the anxiety but it
but it felt more like an imp an
improvement thing not a fixing thing or
not a help please help me thing was i
think my mindset going in honestly
because when it comes to the anxiety
element of it
um
like would you have considered yourself
like
what level of anxiety would you if
somebody was like on a scale of one to
ten how much anxiety do you have how
would you describe that i i'm able to
manage it at like a six is what i would
say
inside the time and well maybe a five
maybe i would have said five or six but
i'm eating but i guess what i'm saying
ultimately like if your baseline level
of anxiety is self-assessed at a six out
of ten yeah i'm no expert but that's
sort of like okay i'm actually well
because i dealt with that so long i was
kind of it just kind of that's just
that's what everybody feels like a
normal but i remember
um going to the cardiologist
back when chris and i were first married
and i worked as an engineer at ibm and
every day i'd come home and lay down on
the couch and
just to chill out and then my heart
would just be like skipping beats and
like jumping out of my chest sometimes i
would wake up in the middle of the night
with like those heart palpitations or
whatever i don't know if that's the
official title
but like um
and i talk i remember i talked i told my
therapist very early on about that and i
was like
that was you know
20 years ago yeah and i but i knew that
it was stress
at least i really hope that it was
stressed because when i sent in the ekg
readings the the text said yeah this
this just looks like you're stressed out
and this so i never followed up with a
doctor and you're like oh of course i
can i can handle that but i kind of knew
and then i would i developed
various coping mechanisms over the years
and just kind of felt like i was putting
the anxiety in its place but there's
also i i think there's also a thing so
then only in certain times would the my
heart rate heart start to flutter like
that when i was in a really stressful
zone
i i mean i i think and i'm not trying to
generalize here but i do think
i am going to generalize so i'm just i
guess i'm just giving a general
generalization disclaimer um that in my
experience there are a lot of men
who based on like certain cultural
pressures and expectations especially if
they are in a relationship with a woman
who is already kind of addressing her
mental and emotional health
i think there's a resistance there's a
resistance to to be like i got i feel oh
i mean
g i got to be the one that's got it
together man like and so even if you
would maybe assess yourself at a 6 out
of 10 of like a baseline anxiety i got
it under control i got it under control
like i'm not about to explode and i i'm
a safe person
and
but and so then you kind of say but you
know she's really the one that needs
help and she's getting the help that she
needs i'm just very and i would have
never said that i'm just saying that
there was a subconscious thought that
just i thought that that's just the way
that it was supposed to work i agree
with that
experience i i relate to that and i
think that it it wasn't fair
to our wives to like put them in that
box it's like okay you're the ones that
need therapy because you have
it what i think was going on was that
they were actually much more in touch
with
um what was going on inside of them and
much more willing to
uh to seek help for it when we were just
out of touch with it and i just kind of
put it in this box
the physical
evidence that there's something going on
deep within side of me that i need to
wrestle with and deal with um
okay and that's why it looked different
and i could say well that's what
you know i would describe well
christy's situation
or
she's the one who needs help because
that's what it looks like but really
what she was demonstrating is an
openness and a b and an in touchness
with herself and i didn't realize that
for me it was a closed off
not willing to go there thing and i just
chalked it up to
differences and i think that and needs
unintentionally there's there there's
this amplification effect that you
actually make the whatever it is that
your partner or your friend
is dealing with
more intense by not addressing your own
problems right so if you're somebody
who's walking around i mean obviously i
got my own
you mean comparing like well no no i'm
not worse than me if you're if you're if
you're going around a 6 out of 10
anxiety based level anxiety
you're not the best person to be to rely
on for someone who's going through those
through those issues you can even
exacerbate the anxiety that she's
dealing with i know i know that i did
that for jesse
as someone who wasn't
processing my emotions in a healthy way
i was not the best resource and again i
don't want to get into like codependent
situation
what i'm saying is that if you actually
want to be the healthiest partner to
your partner who is having their own
issues dealing with your own [ __ ]
is one way to address that when you're
like i don't have anything i don't have
anything to deal with
then you can actually create more of a
burden for your partner who's already
dealing with their own stuff um so i i
went in with this like
optimization
become my best self kind of
thing
and i was willing
to go to
dark places in order to get there but i
was also like how dark can it be
yeah really you know and so
um
i did bring everything i had to it uh
but it you know there's a little bit of
a dance because you're it you have to
ease into it because it's a it's a it's
a relationship you're this is a complete
stranger
with qualifications and reviews and it's
so this dude's checked out
and i feel like we're starting off on a
good foundation but you got to build on
that and you got to talk about yourself
and like you don't expect immediate i i
you know i'm learning that like okay i
don't
want to expect like immediate results
i got to give this some time and let
this blossom
then the pandemic hit
and
a lot of i mean as that
therapy for me evolved into crisis
management like the crisis of the
pandemic and all the pressures
that we then of that you mentioned
earlier filtered through that and
leading the company and
you know
um being a resource for my loving my
family
became a week-to-week crisis you know i
i've i've talked about christie's health
challenges
um
and i'm so grateful that i had gotten in
under the wire and we had met in person
a few times that then and i got in a
slot
with this guy so that i could then
you know when the [ __ ] really started
hitting the fan and boy was it hitting
the fan
for
the majority of that year
every week was just
help me hold this together i think is
what i what i brought to our meetings
now this has happened what how do i deal
with this how do i how do i
how do i respond so it was kind of it
was a survival type thing
and i've described
the low points and all those challenges
so i you know i don't want to go into
that but the but that really impacted
the
tenor uh of of what therapy became
for me for that entire time
and then there was
um you know and then when things are
better or like when the light
shines when the clouds clear for a
little bit and the light shines through
i remember there being a few
um
uh sessions
where
it was actually about kind of
living in that moment of
i'd
i'd walked through all of these
difficult things
and anticipated more
but
with this with this person
that then it was kind of a
it was a it was a sweet
session when we could just kind of
celebrate it
and so i discovered that like that was a
different facet of therapy that like
that the relationship paid off and
it could it could be a positive
celebration of moments of
uh
growth or a gist of survival
um but i'm painting a picture of us not
really getting back to
that like deeper inner work that
was like the thing that i thought i was
signing up for
um
because getting through the day and the
next night and the next week was kind of
all that i had the capacity to focus on
um
so
i would say that
that described a phase of therapy for me
and i you know i'm i'm interested if you
see it that way or how you see it but
then i'll say there's a next phase that
i'm kind of in now which is really great
news that like
there's been enough space between crises
that
i can start to say
what are some deeper things that i want
to work on or places i want to go
um
but it wasn't without a very specific
challenge that related to therapy itself
that i'll get into but i i wanted to
hand it back over to you in terms of
like how you see the trajectory of
building that relationship and has it
gone through phases so my therapist was
jesse's therapist first okay and also
my boys had been to to see him initially
you know actually the the thing that was
the impetus was
uh kind of recognizing that shepard had
adhd
and that was
in somebody recommended
our who is now our basically our
therapist that everyone can see i mean
jesse and are the ones that see him
regularly but
so he had a lot of insight into our
family and i think and again
not every therapist will do that and it
was a long process and there's people
have different opinions about whether or
not a therapist should serve a couple or
a family in that way
for us it's a really good circumstance i
don't think i would recommend it for
everybody but one of the things it did
is
there was a level of trust and
connection and i think actually the
first time i met my therapist was in a
couple session with jessie there
and that was the introduction to like oh
this is this is the guy that she's been
talking about for years and now i i know
who he is and
um so that first session was like
talking to somebody that i already knew
i i think
when that's the way that it starts and
of course if you
if your wife has been going to a
therapist and your wife has been talking
about you in therapy
yeah
you come as a there's a narrative
attached to you right which could be a
negative thing
but i think that jessie was very fair in
the way that she kind of described the
things that i dealt with but then i
immediately confirmed all those things
while meeting and again my main issue
the sort of the
the main sort of ongoing thing that is
my struggle is the fact that i tend to
intellectualize and rationalize my
emotions versus versus just experiencing
them right
so
something comes in experientially
and
there's a natural emotional response to
that thing
whether it be sadness
or anger
whatever
and if it's an inconvenient emotion i
think i've always seen myself as a very
rel you know
self-reliant
super dependable like you can put me
through
basically any circumstance
and i'm gonna be the one person that's
still standing right it's just it's a
pride thing i don't know i don't know
what it is but i've kind of you know
like
give me something else to do
i will not break
give me a new challenge i will succeed
at it
and so negative emotions
feel like wastes of time for me
right being sad about something
well that's like who's got ain't nobody
got time for that you know what i mean
and so what you end up doing is if
there's something that's genuine
genuinely difficult
for me to deal with that should result
in a
an outpouring of grief or sadness
frustration whatever
i will immediately and i'm very skilled
at this
reframe that circumstance
to remind myself that it's actually not
that bad like this is not that bad
lots of people have it worse than you
like you can actually easily get to over
here and see the bright side of this and
see the optimistic side and see the
future of where this thing could go and
i immediately just move to the side and
i get on that track and you know
there's a lot of benefit in that when it
comes to like being successful in in a
capitalistic side society right
um and so i have experienced a
tremendous amount of success in one
sense because of my tendency to not let
myself feel things and just to kind of
but what was happening over time is that
if you continue to do that
those emotions are going somewhere to be
processed usually if it's a sadness that
you're dealing with
then it will be an outburst of anger it
will be a short temper which i
definitely have at times
um and it will be like you oh you you
went you went from zero to a hundred
like what where did that come from
the kids came in and did something and
you snapped at them immediately like
what was
a lot of that comes from
not processing and letting myself feel
things so
that's my main issue there's a lot of
other issues but i'm saying that that's
the main sort of emotional um
sort of misfire that happens repeatedly
with me
and so and that's something that you
discovered you you became acquainted
with it because what i would have told
you and what i would have told jesse is
i would have just told you the positive
side of that thing i would be like i'm
kind of a stoic guy like
you know i can get very enthusiastic
about things and it's not like i don't
cry like i said i'll cry at hallmark
commercials
but
and then when my therapist explained to
me it was like well the reason you do
that is because you're very willing to
feel emotions for other people
like if i go to a wedding i don't care
if i know the people i'm going to cry
if i go to a funeral
i'll most likely cry
but if i'm experiencing something
very rarely will i cry if it's something
that's an emotion that i like i'm the
target of it and i'm the one who's
supposed to feel sadness
i'll deflect it i'll save it you put it
over here in a little jar it's building
up it's got to be that jar's got to be
empty somehow it's either going to come
out as anger it's going to come out as a
motion for someone else
i just always was like i never i never
sorted through any of this stuff i was
just like you know i'm like my dad i'm
just like i'm super dependable i'm not
the emotional person in the room like
i'm not gonna take any of your energy
like if you're in a relationship with me
if you're working with me we're never
going to have to stop to accommodate me
like i'm not that guy
and so i just was like and that's what
makes me great
you know what i'm saying
but what
my therapist was beginning to when jesse
was saying things about it like well you
just you're not just letting yourself
feel this you're not opening yourself up
to this
it was just a couple of meetings as i
explained you know he was like you know
tell me about yourself i mean the first
few meetings were talking about my
upbringing talking about the way i see
things and you know i'm presenting
myself in a certain way and i wasn't
trying to present a good picture of
myself i was like i know i need
something because i mean i got all this
physical stuff happening i don't really
understand what it is because i don't
have the language
to to talk about this
but and my therapist is a is a is a very
good friend now as well right so he can
say
he just tells me like it is and
sometimes but hold on let's not skip
ahead though so
but early on you were telling about
yourself and then you were you were
unpacking these things and he was
helping you come to these realizations
that you've just shared
yeah but like what i'm getting at is
there was an imme immediate relational
connection so i'm not just saying he's a
friend now there's an immediate sort of
relational connection
which
is not necessarily normal or expected i
will just say that it just
worked out that way
and i don't even think it's necessary to
be clear but it in my situation it was
great
but like i specifically remember a time
where i would like explain something and
he just laughed
you know what i'm saying because because
he was observing
how adept i was at moving myself out
away from like you get on the
uncomfortable peak of an emotion and you
immediately dodge it
and he could just observe that happening
and he would be like no no no stop let's
let's stay there with this thing where
do you feel it like where physically and
like the first time he asked me where i
felt something physically i laughed at
him
because i was just like man wait what
does that even mean where do i feel it
like i can't even tell you what i feel
much less where i feel it yeah but you
know i've since we'll get into later
like what i've actually learned and how
i've applied that but that was kind of
my initial experience was like
immediately kind of
understanding what the challenge was and
having it explained to me in a
um
and this is my tendency is i'm gonna
like
try to like academically define what it
was and so right from the beginning i
was like oh this is what's wrong with me
so this is the thing that i need to
start fixing
that happened really quickly mm-hmm
the fix then what the fixing is a
different different process
um
well so i do a session i've consistently
done every other week
not weekly for an hour and a half
instead of an hour uh i well
yeah at least like yeah like a double a
double session so i guess it ends up
being the same amount of time as if if i
was doing it every single week
um
but
and i and it's actually gotten a little
bit shorter recently
in the past year or so it's pretty much
just a single session every other every
other week did it you know when i
described like the crisis thing like i
mean are there times when you're like
this happened or
there's a crisis yeah well
every sec every session and it's
external
it's an external crisis well yeah
obviously there's an internal component
it usually starts with that yeah i
yeah i
i and i still do this it's still my
tendency but i'll i will
start off a session kind of telling him
everything that's kind of going on in
you know no particular order i don't
take i don't have an agenda i don't
really think about it until i see him on
the on the call
and then i'm just like i just start
going and i just start talking and
the things that are
the heaviest
and they feel like the biggest sort of
burden
are the things that become very obvious
very quickly as i talk
and then he'll kind of rewind let's go
go back to this you know and then we'll
kind of talk about
that and again it's it's a it's a subtle
process
of just getting me to actually
understand what it is that i'm
feeling it
it's pretty simple with me because the
issue is so severe you know what i'm
saying i'm sure there's other things to
continue to to to deal with but because
the tendency is to just reframe redefine
and cope versus feel
it's really just like all right let's
talk about that let's see what you're
feeling and so one of the sort one of
the things that i know we're going to
talk a little bit about
uh
how you gauge your own progress
so i don't want to say that now but i
because the issue is kind of singular
for me and yes it will be like we're
having this particular issue and again
because he knows our family so well he
might be like well i already know
the issue that so-and-so is dealing with
no he doesn't tell me anything
you know there's privacy it's a little
complicated but like he if i have to say
well jesse's going through this thing
right now or lock's going through this
thing right now he already has insight
into that because he's already talked to
them about it
which again for me has been a great
benefit
because you got somebody who understands
the dynamics on both sides of the
situation so there are times when you're
walking through
like
processing a crisis but in the general
mode for you is
a like a continual
an exercise of
bringing in your bringing your emotions
to the table and processing things on a
level
on that level like
instead of just the way that you would
left your own devices
pre
therapy yeah it's just kind of sorting
through all that stuff okay because it's
interesting because there's a difference
between vulnerability and emotional
vulnerability
i'm actually
a really vulnerable person in terms of
like i'm not a secretive protective
person if i meet you on the subway which
i don't go on the subway because i'm in
los angeles we call it a metro and i
don't usually take that but
you know i could have a conversation
with somebody
and immediately get into like some deep
stuff and be very
personally disclosing about myself
my issues etc yeah your sh your you can
share things yeah and factually and i'm
a very i'm a very introspective person
meaning that i'm willing to
look at myself and analyze my actions
etc etc
but those are not substitutes
for emotional vulnerability now again
yes i've cried on this podcast
whatever
um but what i'm talking what i'm talking
about is just like
getting to a place where i give myself
permission to feel something like it's
okay you can you can stop and feel this
like
no task is going to be left us
left aside or it's okay for this person
to see you in this state says you know
yeah those issues can get conflated
pretty easily well as an aside i think
we're both very vulnerable here but
there are things that we've decided that
we're comfortable
sharing
but there's moments when
we might be experiencing
something on an emotional level like if
we if we tear up or cry about something
here
that happens much more rarely it's a
different type of vulnerability so even
if you look at it yeah yeah see i'm the
reason why i'm asking like
the questions of like how you go about
therapy and how you view it is because i
feel like even though it's been almost
two years
for me i'm still just getting started
because there was
so much acute crisis to deal with
and there was definitely
i mean i'm not just not saying that
there weren't times when like we we've
made connections between
my my past and how that impacts me now
or what's going on inside of me
and
and definitely i've been processing the
emotional aspects of
the the crisis that i'm going through
and finding
it as a resource i i
i do tend to
over analyze everything and so at
certain points i would describe therapy
as
you know what i feel like if i were just
talking to a wall
and i was disciplined enough to like
verbally process to that wall every week
for an hour
and then kind of that i would come to a
lot of the same conclusions like that's
probably not true that says a lot about
your therapist
it says a lot about me right i
understand exactly i mean i'm just being
honest that sometimes it feels that way
because it's like well how much did he
say
i can talk a lot i can get you know i
can get going and i am such a verbal
processor that like hearing myself is a
huge part of the process for me
and
on the skeptical side i'm like yeah he
only asked me three questions
but how much am i paying
and how much am i paying him but on the
other side it's
those are some pivotal questions
you know
in those moments when i stopped and
thought and answered the question
probably redirected the whole
conversation in a way that the wall
wouldn't mm-hmm but i'm just being
honest with saying you know a tesla wall
i don't know i always feel that way but
i've i've
i know i've noticed in the points when
there's not something that like i feel
like i am
need to run to someone for help
that i'm drowning in some way or that i
want to help somebody else that i love
or something you know if there's not an
emergency
and
the the sessions coming up
i just
really started noticing
the amount of trepidation that i would
bring to it
and this started happening i think
pretty early like i actually
i went through a period of time
in the first year where i would jot down
on my on my phone like
a sentence or two from the therapy
session and i went back and looked and i
realized like a year ago this was
happening
like we had gone through a lot of the
of of of things and like it was one of
those like the clouds it cleared moment
and i jotted down that i was just
i approached the sessions with so much
trepidation because i did not know
what i wanted to talk about
and then i noticed over the past few and
and by the way when that happened i
remember i i cancelled an appointment
and then
it was
and then the next week i like i wanted
to cancel again
and
i ended up talking about it a little bit
instead of canceling the i like i felt
like i confessed it i was like listen i
cancelled on any last week because i was
just too afraid to show up and not
and the unknown just was too much for me
i didn't know what i wanted to talk
about
and then
a lot of [ __ ] hit the fan again or i
guess because over the last few
weeks maybe months
it's come up again and i guess it's a
good sign that like i have the room i
have the headspace
to say
i'm not drowning here i'm not afraid i'm
not
desperate for help about a specific
thing
but my mind immediately goes to now what
i don't that's how i know therapy
so
going back to that first place of like
i'm just going to start working on some
like longer term or deeper issues
shadow work type stuff you know the
the real sexy hard stuff
instead my i would just get frozen with
i
i i don't know what i don't i'm i don't
know what to say and i would get so
stressed out
like
five six days in advance
and
and i would notice the moment that i
would come up with something i'd feel
relief
and i would
i'd realize that like you know this is
what i felt in college every time i had
an assignment until i could finish the
assignment or develop a plan that i knew
i could finish it it would drive me nuts
and
i started to think this might be a good
thing to talk about in therapy
[Music]
but so you know but so my question is
because again like what what i'm hearing
as your friend as you say these things
is just like
yes
the reason that you should be in therapy
is the re is the being
evidenced in the way that you approach
therapy yeah and so when you take this
to your therapist what do you feel do
you
do you feel like
you
there are some and again i understand
it's not about necessarily you're not
necessarily paying them for their
insights
so to speak
it is like paying for time to process
which everybody needs but you are they
you know they are trained professionals
so
do you feel like
when you take that
a year ago when he when i took it to him
uh you know he was like you know what
i i
i want you to feel like you can come
with absolutely blank slate with not
knowing anything
some of the best sessions i have with
people are when they have no clue what
we're going to talk about
and we they still show up
and he encouraged me to think about it
as
i'm prioritizing
my myself and something that i need this
is me time that's protected
um
and
he didn't he didn't say you know you're
not performing for me or you know we
didn't really
he just reassured me at the time it's
like you know what you don't have to
come up with anything
i got this
i can handle this and i could not bring
myself to believe him in action
you know it was difficult and then
more [ __ ] hit the fan
and i had stuff that i felt like was
urgent
and it was
so and then it kind of again it moved to
the back burner but i realized that was
a year ago that was october that i that
i put that in my
um
my my journal my phone journal
and so a few weeks ago
a few sessions ago i brought it up
again and i was like this is still
happening i'm i'm i'm having such a
difficult time i don't know what my hang
up is
and we started to explore like
well i want to make sure
it's worth
my time and my money
i want to
am i afraid that i'm not
demonstrating
that i'm not making the most of this
that i'm not bringing enough to this and
and
my therapist knows it
you know i'm i'm telling him this stuff
at that time and i'm realizing
that there's that there's definitely
barriers there for me
um
to
accepting it as a place that is that's a
non-judgmental zone because it there's a
lot of things going on but one of the
things that i realized was that
i just assumed that he is analyzing me
in the same way that i'm analyzing
the session and myself
and
control is
obviously a big thing for me that i'm
that i'm working on and i see it at play
here that's like when i don't feel like
i can
i have plans meaning that i have control
over
where the therapy starts so then i know
when
when i've gotten to it when i've gotten
to the answer when i've when i've made
the most of the session when i've gotten
my money and times worth
when i've gotten when i've demonstrated
that i'm willing to make progress
because i actually have made progress
because i brought a starting point and
then there was some sort of conclusion i
definitely
found myself towards the end of a
session i i would look at the clock
throughout the session and realize
okay i'm halfway through there's
something else i wanted to talk about so
i'm going to get to that now i would
very much control everything in order to
try to feel
okay about it and then at the end
if it went well i would always i
realized that i would thank my therapist
i don't know if this seems weird
because i wanted to i wanted to
acknowledge to him kind of in like a
code that like
yes you helped me
i got what i needed out of this you know
it's like kind of giving him a review
or and demonstrating that i've made
progress
and i did so all of these things i'm
starting to realize as we're having the
conversation about how
freaking difficult it is for me and how
much
i put on myself and bring into therapy
just because it's therapy
or what i think it should be in my mind
and then i realized that like
you know i haven't
before
going to
therapy in this environment like
the the way that we would do it before
is we would i would go visit i would
have a counselor which would normally be
my church pastor
and i knew that that was not
a judgment-free zone like i always knew
that innately that was like you know a
pastor was always
comparing at least in my mind
comparing my
uh ex like whatever i was confessing
and again i never confessed to a
a catholic priest it wasn't like that
never went into the closet with the with
the catholic priest
just the protestant guy
would be comparing yes well this is
comparing my point of view and my
actions to
the morals of the bible and then saying
okay well this is what this is how you
need to change this is what you need to
repent of this is where you this is
where you're in sin and this is where
you need
this is where you need to uh get right
with god right it was an
implied
place of judgment the exact opposite of
what therapy's supposed to be
right
and i do yeah and it's so difficult for
me to believe
that he's not constantly judging me
because i'm like aren't you coming up
with an assessment don't you have like
like what do you i've been talking to
you for almost for a year and a half
more like
what
what what conclusions are you drawing
about me
what do you know did you ask him that
yeah you know he he said a number of
things that were like
made me feel
they were edifying
but then he basically said that i deal
with um
i can't remember the term he was
basically like
i have anxiety you know and it seems
it's like well it maybe it seems obvious
but and this was just a few weeks ago
and i i know and i harness all of my
neurosis for comedy i i am acquainted
with it enough to use it to my advantage
and and also kind of laugh at myself but
to hear the therapist just kind of say
it in more of like a
diagnosis kind of way it it shook me up
a little bit because it was like um
oh i don't i don't just experience
anxiety
i have
anxiety
it felt different to me
um
and i just uncovered a lot there but
there's a there's a few things that come
up for me as you as you talk about this
i mean one is
the conversation that you're having
with me
right now about your therapy
and you've done this a little bit but it
definitely feels like that's the
conversation that you should be having
with the therapist now you like you said
you you have kind of done that right
yeah because the nature of the way
you're seeing it and the nature of the
conversation that we're having about it
is indicative of what your work is
in the anxiety and control in those
things right yeah i mean if you feel
like when you asked him that question i
mean again it's it's tough it's tough
for me like i don't like i'm not here to
evaluate the effectiveness of your
particular therapist right
there's a part of me that
in the way that like
jesse had already told my therapist a
bunch of things about me
someone who's in relationship with you
which is actually how
something i want to talk about in terms
of how i evaluate what i've actually
experienced in therapy and what the
benefit has been
but also kind of understanding what it
is that your issues are are sometimes
most
eloquently articulated by the people in
your life
because i could have told you yeah i've
gone through that you're going to
therapy with christy
and been able to provide
my perspective that
really kind of coalesced some things
for for christie it's like i feel like
if me and christy could sit down with
your therapist for one hour and just be
like
can we just tell you some things about
link
because i don't know if he is coming
across as he talks to you i don't know
if he's packaging it differently or he
doesn't he doesn't have us he doesn't
have a because who no one has a great
self-assessment right i don't have a
great self-assessment so so but but you
really i mean i think you are and i i'm
totally cool with this that like you are
questioning whether after all this time
couldn't he have like the
couldn't he have gotten do i need a new
therapist well well no i guess what i'm
saying is is that okay as i think back
on our life together first of all there
was a lot like if you take if you take
our life in sections really quickly and
you take like
growing up together
i had absolutely no clue that you were
dealing with so much so much anxiety i
was not like that it was not right
anxiety wasn't my d it wasn't something
i was dealing with you were like nervous
and
shaken up about all kinds of things and
no one had any idea that it was
happening your best friend had no idea
what was happening
then
for most of our adult life
i kind of dismissed a lot of your
anxious
first of all it would be like yes he's
got like once we started working
together i was like oh he's got a lot of
control issues i see that
um and that is interesting and like
creative collaboration but it didn't
feel like a mental problem or like
emotional problems just like link has
control issues it's something that he
understands i understand and we we work
it out
but your anxiety
was something that i did not have a an
understanding of i was just like i know
he's
stressed out quote
unquote because
he's as busy as i am and i know what it
feels like to be this busy and i know
what it feels like to have this much
pressure and have this many projects and
this many employees and all these issues
that we're constantly dealing with like
it's stressful as hell
so and you and we're do everything side
by side so i know that you're stressed
out
but the the anxiety that you bring to
like every type of experience not just
the stressful things is something that i
didn't have a language for until i
started going to therapy and we started
like talking about all this stuff right
and so i've so i've come to understand
like oh like link is running really
really hot yeah that baseline anxiety
that you're talking about
and now okay i see it come out and some
of the things that he says and does this
is like oh that's coming out
because he's so anxious about this thing
right now
and so
to me
and i'm not saying i mean he's told you
that you deal with anxiety i'm not
saying he's a bad therapist but i'm just
like okay we're two years in and he's
like saying that like no man like this
is your this is an issue that like is
very
consequential in your life do you know
what i mean
and so
i just want i mean i guess i'm just what
i want him to do i have a hard time
judging my therapist because i'm just
constantly judging myself no i
understand that and and we do talk about
those things and we do and so it's like
assignments like
think back on memories from your child
like from your childhood let's explore
like your family life growing up like
okay your dad wasn't there then you're
then you're then your stepdad wasn't
there and this is
how you interacted with your mom it's
like we do
talk about those things and it does and
it has shed light on
uh my impulse to control and
uh
the the roots of my
anxiety right and the control being the
thing that is
you're trying to get hold of the anxiety
with the control right i didn't even
yeah i talked we talked about this i
didn't even realize until like
six months ago
that a lot of the things you told me in
situations where you vote you were just
vocalizing something to yourself but you
were telling me because i'm i'm with you
you know what i'm saying like and then
i'm like oh he does that a lot like he's
like
now don't forget to make the most of
this or what
you say something to me and i'm like
and for years i was always just like
yeah you're right man it's like i don't
i didn't really need to hear that but uh
you're right in what you just said all
of a sudden it hit me it's like
oh
he's he's he's self-soothing right now
yeah by saying this thing to me
and so i guess what i'm saying is this i
just want to i just want to sit down
with your therapist and be like
because i want to hear him talk and i
want to know like do you really
understand this guy do you understand
him i mean
i do think that
my work is
like understanding what i'm what i'm so
afraid of
um
and i think
that
i don't you know it's
do i need a new therapist
really hard it's it i mean i have i mean
christy's been through different
therapists it's very uh other people
that i know have been
most people that i've talked to that i
know really closely about therapy have
been to multiple therapists and
sometimes they've gone back just to know
what they may have been missing well so
i actually feel like if you were to ask
and i feel like i would like to start
over anyway it's like something about
the way that it again we talk about it
we talk about two weeks ago we have so
much and so it's an opportunity to kind
of change the trajectory to not be so
crisis-oriented
we talked about that specifically and
that's why we got into the
you know reflect more on your past and
we can unpack some of that
and talk about this impulse to control
like
this is where we're
where we've talked about going
but i do wonder
there is a part of me that's like i feel
like i gotta have somebody to i gotta
have a different experience with a
different person to compare it to yeah i
i mean i can't advise you in that i'm
just i'm just i guess because i i i
think the thing that i feel like i'm
missing is like
i
i i would i just anticipated that i
would be breaking down left and right in
therapy
i mean
i just don't i
you know i've got a [ __ ] ton of issues
but it's not like i don't think i have
the issue you're talking about where i'm
not gonna
like
weep about my own
you know
emotion let that emotion out
you know i actually
i actually think that i
i i thought what i thought i was signing
up for i thought i was signing up for
crying a lot and you know
and because i haven't and i just feel
like
i feel like that's a reason to look for
see if another therapist can get me to
cry more because
uh
i thought that's i thought that was
going to be part of it that's an outward
sign for me
that i'm getting somewhere and it may be
i mean as somebody who just to put
things into perspective as somebody
who's been going to therapy since 2017
specifically
focusing on being able to feel things
and process things i still haven't cried
and my wife just laughs at me i mean not
in jess but just because she's like i
cry every damn time
um
but do you think that i
would listen i'm not at least a few
times like i want a breakthrough i guess
it's one of my here's what i'll say i
want to be really
hesitant to like
because i'm not
a professional by any means well i know
that it's just i know how to filter your
advice and comparing it to my experience
where the way that i would categorize
the way i would characterize what
happened with me is
very very quickly we got to the root
and now when we got to the root
we saw that the root was really thick
and really deep and splayed out in many
different areas so it's not like just
identifying the issue solves it because
i still have all the tendencies
but
it didn't take it took two sessions
not two years to get to the root yeah
and like i feel like we're like
we're
certainly digging in the in the right
place
but
um and there's reasons why maybe it's
taking this long to get back to it but i
feel like um
that i can't continue the root analogy
and talking about the point i'm trying
to make
uh what is the point i'm trying to make
well how well okay
this is uh i i'll talk a little bit
about
because i recently oh i know what i was
trying to say we're looking in the right
place like saying this is this is the
root of the issue and i'm envious of the
way that like
now you kind of know well i'm envious i
feel like you've described an assignment
like you bring the therapy your life and
then you make sure that you're
processing it on a level that you
haven't been able to ex until therapy
unlocked that for you an emotional level
so
the
the protocol seems clear to me again
it's a plan i feel like
and
so is my exercise to find someone new
who can give me that breakthrough and
then filter
filter every experience i have through
the trauma that i've endured as
as a child that then is making me want
to control
everything to soothe it or
do is my exercise
that and
also letting go of the control of
needing a plan to get there and
analyzing that's what makes it really
complicated
for for you and
in a different way
again
because i like to present myself as
having it together and i do it
unconsciously
again i don't know what
now i'm not going to get into the way
the what i've explored specifically
about
you know my childhood that kind of
potentially led me to a place that this
is the way that i cope with things
but because
i present as someone who's got it
together
as a default
sometimes it takes
30 minutes of talking and therapy to
begin to break through the shell because
i'm doing it without even knowing it
just like i think i i think things are
going pretty good
but they're not like they they may be
externally but like in here no there's
something that you're not really yeah
you gotta i gotta bring that out so yeah
there is this i'm constantly
what i'm saying is that my issue does
directly impact the way that i do
therapy so i'm not saying that like
every time i i start a therapy session
i'm like here we go i know what the work
is let's do it no the work
is directly related into the way that i
approach therapy in a very similar way
just a different issue
but i feel like my therapist is so
attuned to that being the problem that
he will just be like okay let's stop a
second
now
do you see what you did there you've
been talking about this for this much
time and you see how quickly you move to
this thing
but what about this thing
and so because he's like i'm dealing
with a guy if if it was like he was a
coach and it was just like the thing
this guy can't do is he can't go to his
left right
there's a there's a level of authority
there i'm
i'm envious to that too because i feel
like you don't feel like he's sort of
enough yeah like
he's like stop when you said that
could that mean this it's like
i just don't
i feel like it's all up to me it's like
he's gonna answer he's gonna ask a
question and he's gonna you know what
else am i gonna say now what am i going
to say to the wall the fact that you've
now referred to him as a wall multiple
times makes me think
listen i don't want it again
everybody's experience is different but
because there's a question in your mind
but i think it's a style thing i don't
think it's a criticism of him as much as
like am i discovering what i need and
it's like it's just a it's a
relationship so it's a style
right he's a the therapist is a person
so i i just i'm really feeling like i
going to try somebody else just because
i
it's just a fit it's a style it's a you
want to go my therapist dude
no that would be unethical we can't like
at some point the circle has to stop
expanding i mean could it be a handoff
like maybe you take the weeks and i'm
not there no again
this is two very very non-professional
guys talking about therapy but i think
the the only thing that i i
i want to affirm
is that i don't think it's wrong to
think
should i just could i try something else
out i know it's not wrong and i know
that they do it all the time yeah
and but it's like it i get hung up on it
and i'm definitely thinking that i'm not
going to tell him
i'm just going to get a second therapist
at the same time wow
i don't know how i feel about that
i should be able to tell him he's my
damn therapist yeah but say hey i'm
breaking up with you for a little time
until i changed my mind and realized
that the grass wasn't greener and then
i'll come back to you he knows all of
that it happens all the time right
i could just be like because because i
think you have to talk to him about it
the temptation is
i'll just go to every other week and
then i can i can hedge with somebody
else i think the whole point is i got to
build the other person back up while i
taper the other guy off well i feel like
i don't want to be i don't want to be
left in a league this is the thing this
is the thing i was kind of getting at
earlier is that i feel like
there's the real narrative that's
happening in here
and then there's the curated narrative
that you bring to your therapist and i
think that and i do the same thing
but the but i didn't know you were
saying that but but what i'm cause no
because i'm performative in a different
way right i'm definitely performative i
okay but you're
but you're that i'm getting you're
trying to control it and get the most
out of it and make it the best possible
session i'm just trying to appear like i
got it together yeah even if i don't
but they're both performative in a
certain way so the thing that he breaks
me out of is the curated narrative
and
either you've got to break yourself out
of the of narrative or or if i don't
have a curated narrative whatever it is
i just want to have more of a
i think his style is more like
raise a question
and then it's self-discovery but it's
not
it's not a conversation we're not
batting ideas back and forth
well you know this is where i want a
little more of that this is a way that
we we tell people who work for us and
work with us this all the time because
if there's anything that we are
we have been very much in common in the
way we work with people is we invite
collaboration really intensely and we
tell people we're gonna when we get
ready to work on a project we say listen
you can't offend us
and we don't hold any ideas sacred if
you don't like something you should tell
us
because that's how we work and listen if
you step back
and you make it a light touch thing and
you don't ever voice your opinion we
will bowl over you because we have so
much intense creative energy
now i i actually think we kind of
function relationships in this way and
so i think what you're asking it's like
when i have something to bring you you
want him to you know i bowl over i
talked to the wall yeah you wanted to
reach out and grab you by the collar
yeah so to speak and again i feel like
my therapist does that in
the most respectful friendly way
possible but he just kind of is ready to
when he smells [ __ ]
he says i smell [ __ ]
you know what i mean i don't know what
he needs to maybe maybe there's a
different scent from me a different
stink than [ __ ] but
yeah it's not whatever that is i would
like to be uh
so i think you got to talk to him and i
think you got to say that i'm just you
know i you know this is this is how i
feel and
what i want to do is maybe
meet with someone else because i just
don't have anything you know i don't
have any sort of
connection to compare this to and then
i'll see what he's starting over you
know it's like that's why i haven't done
it
and that's when when things go when
things go better
um and i have that like i don't have
anything to talk about i'm like i'll
just i'll stretch it out
i'll just meet every other week
we'll try that out maybe i don't need
therapy i i start to tell myself that
stuff okay and then i know i know what
this is this is what i wanted to talk
about because i started to think the
same thing okay
um
and i actually asked jesse when we were
getting ready for this episode i was
like i feel like
i understand what my problem is and i
understand what i'm
kind of what i'm doing to work on it but
it's really difficult for me to talk to
articulate the progress
and what's actually changed and she was
like well do you want me to tell you
right and so i actually wrote down some
of the stuff that she said because i
asked her to repeat it okay
um
first of all she kind of laughed again
she and it's like would you want me to
tell you what what i've seen she's like
you're much more in touch with your
which is translated into the way that we
communicate me and her communicate
spent you know been married for 20 years
spent many of those years if we were
arguing about something my main goal was
to get a point across to debate to be
like this is why i think that i'm right
about this and these are my supporting
this is the supporting evidence
versus worrying about connecting
do you know what i'm saying or just
saying
this is how i feel like i've literally
changed the way that we argue about
things by saying
well this is what this is what i'm
feeling right now and it isn't i feel
that you're a jerk about it this is like
no this is the emotional response that
i'm having right now and she's already
there because she's been doing and
that's completely changed the way that's
changed conflict of resolution i didn't
even know that until she pointed it out
she's like
you don't get mad as much
i mean again that's something that i
didn't really have a no you really don't
have a
a way to to perceive yourself in that
way
um
she said we are closer than we've ever
been
and i was like well you know i recently
told somebody that i thought that too
oh is that something to do with
emotional therapy yes okay
uh and then she says and think about the
way that we
the differences in the way that we deal
with our kids since before therapy
you know one of the things that
our therapist has really
harped on
is this maintaining the relationship
with our kids as they age
and as you as they get older and get
more independent you know like being a
senior in high school
resisting the urge to datify every
situation and to moralize and to correct
and to teach and to use every
conversation as an opportunity to give
my wise perspective versus using every
conversation as an opportunity to
connect emotionally
and again that's just not something that
i'll ha i love my kids i love being with
my kids i love doing things and having
fun with my kids
but usually if they start talking about
something my default is to be like
robot analyze situation give solution
like it's just my personality you bring
me a problem i'll come up with a
solution real fast
versus bring me a problem and let me let
me get into let me get behind that
problem with you let's not solve it
let's just agree that it's a problem and
connect emotionally these are things
that have happened
but i needed my wife to point them out
so i guess my question for you is i i
think before you make any of this
decision you got to talk to christy
about it oh sure
we're already talking about yeah but
like if she were to be like
oh no like i
just i've seen this changing in this in
these in these ways or just be like no i
think you need a new therapist like
she's gonna know way better than me well
we we had a fight last night
but we're having a we're having a date
tonight okay
good to get the fight out of the way
well the fight was the conflict was
resolved but i did not i kind of showed
my ass so i didn't really demonstrate a
lot of progress in any area
so uh i don't know how if tonight is a
good night to ask
because she might be like uh
there's some work to be done i mean
that that is the sense i get you know
it's like the in
in an effort to wrap this up i think
just the benefit of kind of looking back
the other thing was that i looked back
at my notes
and they ended a year ago i stopped
jotting down
i think i want to start that back up
because
i'm sure christy can give me perspective
on
uh all of this and i'll put that
question to her
in terms of like
how i've changed or grown
if at all i know i i i believe i have
um i've definitely survived a lot of
things i couldn't and that is saying a
lot and it's not something to diminish
you you've had you've had acute
situations yeah it took a lot of energy
and time but um
i do think i want to i want to keep
writing things down and i and i am going
to seriously consider getting a new
therapist i think that came from within
me that's not something that you were
that's your that wasn't your idea was
their best listen to this podcast
why would he i don't think it doesn't
seem right my therapist doesn't listen
to it because every time he refers to it
he calls it ear buds
so
yeah yeah just keep it that way
i don't think i don't think he would and
i do not correct him because it's my way
to know if he's actually listening
um boy this this is this is
therapy is tough
what have we learned is this a ringing
endorsement no
to me
you know and it's funny because we we
i've had two conversations in the past
month with two close friends
one who just started therapy and feels
the need to change therapists and one
who just started therapist and wanted to
check in with me after a few sessions
and just ask the question like
it's hard to evaluate
and he and he was
thinking about it from a financial
perspective which is a note we want to
make i mean
being able to pay for your own mental
health
uh is a privilege that we have it's the
luxury sadly um sadly that's that's the
case but we were talking to hades you
know before the show akiko and jenna and
they were both kind of reminding us
about like
you know there are
mental health um
resources and groups and there there are
actually there's free resources for
depending on your your background and
things that you deal with in the
community you live in yeah how big it is
there are ways to get at some of the
stuff
uh there's affinity gross like lgbtq i
mean if that's you know or um
there's
support groups yeah and sometimes that
can happen in a group setting and and
doesn't necessarily have to be
one-on-one but if you can afford it
um
you know try to make it happen but but
he was asking that question because he
was like you know i'm spending a fair
amount of money on this and just like
what like you know and i find myself
like he was he's a lot he's not like you
but it was funny because he did
something that you would have done which
is he printed out like a summary of
himself
with background information like a
resume that you give to a therapist and
send it to the therapist before the
appointment yeah to kind of get it out
of the way so they didn't have to spend
a bunch of time talking i love that idea
and he was like the therapist was like
no one has ever done this
i don't know how to feel about it but
thank you
really
so but i told him the same thing i was
like listen man like i had to ask jessie
to be because i can't immediately
articulate you forget what's actually
happening therapy rolls around and i'm
just like oh man i just want to watch tv
i don't find myself longing for my next
therapy appointment if i have to miss it
and i end up going a full month i don't
feel the need you get secretly happy no
i don't get secretly happy but i don't
have this felt need of like all this
stuff building up that's about to
explode the moment that the zoom call
starts
but then what i find is that when the
zoom call does start and i just start
letting it flow it's there that's that's
your mo it's there right yeah so um
so you're recommending therapy
i'm recommending therapy but it's but
it's not yeah it's not gonna be like
some easy thing my actual recommendation
to wrap things up is um
a book that i've been reading called why
we sleep by i think his name is michael
walker let me just make sure that's his
name
matthew walker
um this is like a new york times
bestseller a few years ago
and it's basically just
all about sleep and the importance of
sleep
now i will say that as i've dug into it
a little bit that there are some people
some researchers out there who question
some of the conclusions he comes to okay
uh but but so much of the book is him
just saying
this was a study a peer-reviewed study
that was done with these people and this
is what it you know he explores all
these different aspects of sleep and you
will learn a lot of really good
information
but i've just been absolutely blown away
at
how just to re reminded at how important
getting a good night's sleep is like if
you don't want to read the book then
just get it going
seven to nine hours of sleep every
single night this would be my
recommendation hey i like that um but
if you're interested in that kind of
information if i could sleep with my
therapist this maybe all my problems
would be yeah right and i don't mean
like that yep well i understand but it's
a good book in general with a lot of
absolutely fascinating information that
you had like here on like a podcast or
like npr all put together into a really
fascinating book all right
well hashtag girbiscus let us know uh
what you think about this you don't have
to give me advice i've got a i got
enough people in my life to to help me
with that but i
uh any other way that you're um
dealing with this or if you want to give
red advice use hashtag
i'm sure you will
talk at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]